[Music]
hey what's up guys this is Thursday and
we call it thoughtful Thursday so the
topic of today is going to be should you
buy from a deal sorcerer or not what are
the pros and cons so I've got my guests
on Alastair Cunningham and you are a
deal sorcerer certainly I am and you've
been packaging and selling deals for a
year or so yep
I reckon I don't know what the largest
or most successful deal packaging
company in the country is I don't know
but you must be up there one of the best
if not the best I believe so I believe
that we are the quickest and the best
that mix air matching investors to
properties so how many properties do you
package and sell each month about 18 to
to 18 22 apologies so what do you think
let's just really discuss this as it's
thoughtful Thursday let's look at the
pros and cons get thoughtful about its
get formal about this as someone
watching this someone who's interested
in getting into property yeah would you
advise someone buy from a sorcerer or
what should they just find their own
properties I think do you know it's a
question I get a lot and I think it
depends on the person it depends on the
investor it depends on their knowledge
level it depends on things like how much
time they've got and I believe that
anyone that buys from us also should
know what they're looking at yeah I
don't think anybody should buy from our
sources that's just so many there's so
many bad sources that's why I don't
think that's why I think they should all
know what they're looking at but even if
they're buying from a good sorcerer or I
personally I used to source properties
myself I don't do it anymore no you do
it and no we work together but well I
don't do it anymore because I am so
passionate that all I think the best
thing to do is to just get the knowledge
yeah you know I think everyone should
have the knowledge I think the knowledge
is key so you never want you to get the
knowledge and and source properties
themself then is that not a little bit
hypocritical ye then running a sourcing
company no because I think everybody
should have the knowledge so that know
what they're looking at but I deal with
many investors that just simply do not
have the time
they've got knowledge but they don't
have the I buy properties well yeah you
probably through me because you've got
all the time that's true and we as a
company we're not really looking for
ambassadors of knit like that are that
I've never got property and I've never
done the Nala the only thing is the
worst type of investors to sell a deal
toe on newbies I believe so yes that's
my experience yeah because like yeah
they are
because newbies number one ask a million
and one questions yeah and then hours
will get the training anyway yeah number
two they just don't they just don't know
what a good deal is now the problem I
see a lot is when newbies come along
they see this portly things of it was a
good deal then they go out and view it
but because their expectations or they
feel that because of and from a source
or like it's a hundred percent
guaranteed results it's a hundred
percent guaranteed rental income and
like it needs minimal work they don't
really listen properly when you try it
when you're speaking about it and also
they'll sign the tip terms and
conditions and stuff but they wait no
really probably you look and now they'll
only hear what they want to hear yeah
so hundred and then six months later if
there's any issues if there's a leak on
the roof it'll be your fault
yeah and similarly it's like JIT if I
could pay someone two thousand pounds to
make sure that I had guarantee that the
property was always going to be filled
it was always gonna be filled a good
tenants there's never ever gonna be any
madness issues or problems with the
house
there wasn't maybe any problems or
holdups of the solicitor's everything
was gonna go perfect well I pay my two
three thousand miles every time I pay 10
grand every time I think no if you could
guarantee if you when you were selling a
property if you could guarantee that
then then you wouldn't charge two or
three grand you charge ten or twenty
grand
exactly the thing is all concern to
expectations what is it then what are
they paying for someone buys you three
thousand pounds or whatever it is what
are they actually paying you for so
they're paying from us doing the lead
leg work essentially so a busy investor
that hasn't got time to travel trips a
country looking at all these houses for
instance for us to find one house we've
probably looked at twelve to fourteen
properties yeah and we've done all the
legwork looking at them houses so we
might expand the day in half on the road
to look at one house and to find one
successful deal so we've done the
legwork we've done did you diligence
we've found local agents we've assessed
the property the condition
and we've done basically all legwork for
them but we're not it's not a guarantee
that it's going to rent out we've done
the homework to make sure that there's
good rental demand
yes presumably if someone's buying from
you you're it's a package deal so y'all
have done y'all have done the due
diligence say you'll give them the facts
and the spreadsheets and the figures and
put them in touch of the agents and what
kind of stuff but it's been again it's
not a 100 percent okay no and that's
nothing
of course it's not what I have had a few
instances where we have sold properties
and they've been complete three or four
months and then you get a phone call
from them because there's suddenly a
problem in the property like electrics
or something goes wrong and they want in
like us to refund them the fund finder's
fee because the property had a problem
six months later
yeah and that's like it's not realistic
come on it's yes we are introducing them
to a property yeah they've got to be
realistic and before completion you know
though that however long it takes two
months three months to do all their own
research surveys and do all the surveys
and do all the stuff so okay so you're
buying from a dealer packager to save
yourself time yeah is that is there
anything wrong with mine from a deal
package because you don't know how to
find the deals but would it be a would
it be a fair enough thing you say
someone's reasonably new they're a
business person they understand
investments but they haven't they
haven't got their knowledge to go find
HMOs they haven't got the understanding
and they say look I'll pay you two three
four grand whatever it is and I just
want you to just figure it all out for
me oh there is there is a case for that
as long as they understand the risks of
that because if they don't understand
what a good a good investment is they
need to understand the risks of just put
in their faith in somebody else now I do
have a lot people do that I have a lot
of overseas investors do that they don't
have they're not going to come over here
and look and they they've got the
knowledge to look at the numbers but
they they're not gonna they don't even
actually view the property for instance
yeah and so they're sort of taking my
ward and reputation however what I did
see as well if I get like a complete
newbie come up to me I listen to them on
the phone and if I'm not convinced they
know what I'm talking about
I just send up the crash course I just
say look just get the crash course
making that's the safest thing to do in
my opinion the safest investment is to
invest in yourself I believe so yeah
well if you if you if you invest in a
property you can go wrong
you bet in a property saucer and pay
them a fee go wrong if you invest in
yourself yeah get the knowledge no one
can ever take that away from you and you
can't blame anybody else for a move on
that's the thing well what is the only
thing they know wrong when you invest in
yourself is that you yo implement yeah
that's down to you that's us in the
right corner knowledge 1% yeah as long
as you don't go you know but but I think
I personally think the old packaging is
gravity it's a great way to save time
I've just made poor man a few thousand
pounds and they found me a great
property and my thinking is well if I'd
have found that myself it would have
taken me at least a couple of days yeah
so you properties or estate agents like
these days 50% of the time the estate
agent doesn't show up like ants at the
last minute case in point now so I can't
be bothered I stand outside in the rain
yeah you know calling me a just I'd
rather pay Porter than 3 grand
I know I know how to find it myself but
it's gonna take me a couple of days and
that's night I Drive up you probably
three hours away depending on where it
is so I'd rather pay someone a fee in
last Thursday I was out with a couple of
people for their viewings
we had 11 viewings boot we only got in
five sites inside five houses there we
go
and that's the colors so they sell
something well it was was tenants
wouldn't let us in agents didn't show in
the past day-to-day life of properly
sourcing now for a deal packager maybe
that's now you've got deals packaging
business yes so you got to start a bit
different for someone that's just
starting out and they're brand new and
their deal packaging if an estate agent
doesn't turn up it's not a massive deal
because they're learning yeah and
they're out on the road and they're
learning and for a lot of people just
starting out if you can do just do sell
one deal a month for make three grands
cuz we take two or three days to find a
deal packages selling the rest of them
at both yes I think the thing is
everyone is at a different season in
their life mmm-hmm everyone's a
different season but you know sometimes
I'll sell deals
yeah I'll come across you know although
I don't have a oh I don't set out to
sell deals but I come across an
opportunity and I'm like you know what
it's great but it's outside of my past
sure it doesn't fit my strategy or I've
just got so much going on right now by
it I'll pass it on an old charge a fee
yeah but then the next week or the next
month I'll bake someone a fee and that
that happens all the time in the Academy
yes sometimes people will sell sometimes
people will buy I think it's a strategy
that everyone should have in their tool
but I do but it should be the gain thing
so when you go and look at houses if you
can't buy it you've got that knowledge
and strategy that you can then pass it
on so I would never discount deal sauce
on a deal plate does concern me
sometimes though we've all these people
selling especially when people are
selling no like rent to sa deals and I'm
just thinking if it's a no money down
rent to its ideal then why are you
selling it yeah I'll tell you the reason
why is because Muslims don't stack no
rather charge five grands make a quick
pop yeah and then disappear I would be
very careful you know what I hate and
you see this day-to-day on social media
people advertising deals on social media
so the advertising like very latest rent
rent deal the lists over there forever
deals because they don't static they
just do not did start would you mind er
now cuz I think it's in I think it's
unprofessional
appetizing a deal on Facebook know
whybut eyes my crush was on banana yeah
but you don't know I just don't agree
with it I know it's a good deal some
professional I think is unprofessional
because I would rather advertise my
service on Facebook and get the customer
into my database as opposed to just
dinner one day I'll tell you why right
because if you have sighs a deal on
Facebook you might get two three bill
message here yeah because if you have
tied your service on Facebook well as a
deal package are so if you advertise my
mailing list on Facebook yeah
so for instance say say an investor sees
the deal but they're not interested in
it so they won't contact you but if they
know that you're a deal package are and
you do lots of the deals they haven't be
more inclined to join you I'm not going
to argue because the end of the day
you're the best thing they could read
this and and and when you have deals I
know you sell
within minutes I saw two deals this
morning so yeah and you do and you drop
an email out in itself you know it's I
think the scariest thing is people
advertising deals on Facebook that don't
stack mm-hmm especially when they you
know reputation yeah haven't got any
come back home got terms and conditions
well I'd say to anybody that's gonna buy
off a deal sorcerer is understand the
deal yourself and make sure don't just
think because you're buying it from a
deal was also there is a guaranteed it's
not what the comeback is yeah so you
know if the deal goes wrong because
whenever you look at it whenever you
look at any whenever you go to any
business decision you doors look a best
case worst case lightly house if the
worst case if the deal package or is
saying look if the figures aren't what I
said and if it turns out to not work out
and you're not happy what you viewed the
property and stuff like that then
there's a you can get a refund so you
know then then that's not a problem
because okay well worst case is I'll get
a refund especially if the deal pocket
just got a reputation yeah so they have
they will have to do what they said
because otherwise they'll be damaging
the reputation no problem but always
look at what's the best case what's the
worst case what's the likely case yeah
worst case if the worst case will find
actually [ __ ] you then don't do it
yeah don't don't don't get a loan out
don't get a loan out of a bank or borrow
money from your grandma to put it all in
with some deal sorcerer that promised
you the world who you've just met on
Facebook just be sensible I'm all for
taking action common sense is feels
birthday unfortunately there are people
you know that will I think what happens
is especially people are new to property
they get so excited about getting that
frost deal yes the the gloss over all
the imperfection and they think if it's
a renter if it's a rent to rent it must
be brilliant yeah but no is it a good
rent to rent here you know all sorts no
money down doesn't mean should take it
no because it might be no money down but
then you might lose money monthly yeah
exactly
also there's also I know the stand was
going on on like places like Gumtree
yeah from the other side from landlords
don't you've seen this yeah yeah then
pretend that they're tired landlords and
they go oh yeah I'm happy to give it you
on a writ to read but actually the
probably doesn't exist
you know and they put it on Airbnb yeah
they say me I'll tell you what just pay
for six months on Airbnb and then we'll
sort your contracts come out the country
yeah Sina so again how would you how
would you avoid again common sense don't
pay anything to like just I don't know
common sense make well what is common
sense how would you avoid being scammed
watch someone on gumtree
um I would want to you wanna you take
people's money before they've seen the
house yeah I do take money some people
in there that's not common sense some
people would say why earth would you pay
Alastair when you've not seen the house
yeah I agree with that but I've got good
terms and conditions in place and a good
reputation and I'll speak to anybody
whereas most of these Gumtree leads you
can't ever speak to any but it's all
done by email there's never any personal
quote like personal touch I'm accessible
I have a website I have all my address
all my details on the website I'm like I
say you could anyone can contact me yeah
I'm not here today gone tomorrow yeah
whereas these Gumtree guys are I do hope
you're not putting me in the same
categories he's probably not at all so
my thoughts are my thoughts are feel
free to pay a sorcerer but only if you
know how to do yourself and you're
trying to save yourself time yeah
because or you just have no intention of
going it here's another one if you've
known tension in going into property mhm
and you've got a business that's making
a lot of money and you want to dump that
profit into property yeah but you can't
be bothered you don't got the time or
the inclination to learn about property
then fine find a good person you can
trust you that can find the properties
do all the hands and feet on the ground
stuff pay them no problem yeah if you
have the knowledge and you want to save
yourself time no problem but don't think
it's a shortcut you know get the
education cuz otherwise deal packages
will pull the wool over your eyes 100
you can make a deal look fantastic on
paper yeah but in reality it can not
stuck up from those there's too many
dodgy deal sources though though well
unfortunately there's good and there's
bad people in every industry there's
good and bad you know in every industry
there's always good and bad people so so
just get the knowledge I think I'm
completely room every YouTube video I
ever do whether it's thoughtful Thursday
whether it's winners Wednesday whether
it's mentoring Monday the conclusion is
get educated and get the knowledge so I
agree with you I wouldn't be where I'm
at today for the ngage kid yeah all over
your eyes you know by from deal packages
also if you if you if you want to learn
about property a really good way to
learn is to do so to pay a deal packager
you're actually robbing yourself from
the experience of figuring out the
process that really is I actually became
an accidental deal sorcerer I didn't
choose to do deal sourcing yeah it's
because I was out doing all like looking
all the time you were looking for a
lease option agreement yourself and
anyway Lutz
yeah and just know what you do all these
deals so I thought ideal sourcing that's
right but because I was out there doing
it learning so yeah I just go there I
encourage people to do deal packaging
but again if you're on the other if
you're a deal packager do it but just do
it properly yeah do it ethically only
only sell a house that you would be
prepared to buy yourself yeah if you
were under the right circumstances to
buy it I think it comes down to the
person you know because the the doesn't
more what business as persons that Logie
persons in they could make deal source
and doji's they could make buying cars
and selling cars dodgy if they're a
dodgy 10 person will always be dodgy
they're good people they're always good
I mean if you're the kind of circles
like I know with us at the crash course
on the Academy you know we've got dozens
of deal packages on the Academy they're
all brilliant they're all very ethical
yeah you know because they've been
trained well that's awesome so if you're
considering buying a property from a
deal packager do it but get the
knowledge first so they cannot pull the
wool over your eyes one honey if you're
a deal packager continue doing it kick
some ass but do it ethically and always
make sure you look after your clients
yeah absolutely agree so that's this
week's thoughtful Thursday we'll be here
same time next week put your comments
below subscribe also if you've got any
questions bang-on below and we'll do our
best to answer see you next time
[Music]